Oh my gosh, am I live?
I can't tell sometimes.
Good luck, Salantine.
Good luck.
Ended up not.
Salantine is going to try his best.
I'm almost certain the first one is what this team is going
to do against us.
It's going to be Katz.
Yeah, it's fine.
Doesn't really matter.
Tweet out that I'm live.
I'm alive.
Has everybody looked at the Dropbox UPS?
Yes, we talked about it as well.
Good luck, sound team.
We already discussed it.
We're going to individually adjust people on Discord because
everything is connected.
Good luck.
All right.
Hello.
Oh, never mind.
I see you guys.
I just wanted to make sure that you guys were all good
because I saw that you guys were missing one player.
All right.
Anybody here?
Olive, odds, huge.
Yeah, no.
My game is not capturing.
We are, are.
Production are.
Castors are.
Not on.
All right, I'll just go ahead and check with the other team
and make sure that they're ready and we'll get started
shortly.
Just keep an eye on that and I will let you guys know.
I'm not on admin mode.
Thank you.
Olive, where are you?
Are you in America?
Why do you have 90 ping?
Yeah, I'm American.
I'm in Montana, and I live in the middle of nowhere.
This is bad, guys.
My first game might just be, like, a blank screen.
I get, like, 30 lower ping when I'm at my college.
It's crazy.
Wow.
Listen.
Do you go to college in Montana?
Yeah, I do.
Oh.
Yeah, we have schools here.
That's crazy.
No.
You got schools over there in Montana?
you got education we're going you're not gonna see anything
on my screen you're not gonna okay we're banning magic first
they're protecting cat i'm not using i don't really care uh
then i'm gonna ban elsa then i'll try to ban mantis then
they're gonna try to protect i don't know what they're gonna
protect last band is up to us really now i'm too okay guys
we're gonna stop screen we're gonna stop the stream the band
thing i'm protecting i'm gonna try to fix this I'll be right
back, guys.
I'll be right back.